اذا وهذه الصور ننقلها لكم هذه الفيديوهات
التي وصلتنا مقطع متداول لدوريات من الجيش
السوداني اثناء تمشيط شوارع ام درمان وكنا
تحدثنا بحوافقه بيانات للجيش التي عرضوها
في الساعات المقبله بانهم اعلنوا سيطرتهم
واتمام السيطره خصوصا على المراكز
والمنشات الحيويه والرئيسيه في هذه
المناطق حيث اندرمان هي احدى مدن ولايه
الخرطوم احدى مدنها الرئيسيه الثلاث نتحدث
عن اندرمان خرطوم والخرطوم بحري حيث هي
هذه المناطق التي تتركز كانت فيها
الاشتباكات والاعين عليها بعد ان وصلت
الاشتباكات وللمره الاولى يشهد السودان
بان تكون العاصمه هي مركز ومحور للصراع
والقتال الدائر بين
الطرفين العسكريين المسلحين لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات